-Texas and Mississippi announced
that they're lifting
their COVID restrictions,
including mask mandates
against the strong warnings
of public health officials,
and the same Republicans,
putting workers in harm's way
are also silent
on a courageous drive
to unionize Amazon workers.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We are tantalizingly close
to what could very well
be the end of
the COVID pandemic.
No one knows exactly
when that could happen.
Predictions for when
we'll hit herd immunity
and return to normal range
from as early as April
to as late as Christmas.
But we know with vaccines
ramping up
and cases trending down,
especially as we get
closer to summer,
there are genuine reasons
for optimism.
And I know it's hard to believe.
When I hear good news,
it's like when a vegan
eats a cheeseburger.
My body
doesn't know what to do with it,
but it knows it's good.
Our souls have all been ground
to dust by a relentless winter
and a year
of being trapped indoors,
drinking gin straight
from the bottle
and bingeing increasingly
obscure TV shows.
It got so bad I downloaded
a German streaming service
called
Unterhaltun fur die Menschen
to watch a crime show that takes
place in Baden-Wuerttemberg,
starring famed German character
actor Albert Van Mueller-Schmidt
as Detective Otto Jaegerhauer.
Oh, man, let me tell you,
episode three
is a real "clippenbugel."
That's German for cliffhanger.
Anyway, the point
is we're so close,
we can't screw it up now.
We need to spend the next two
or three months
really crushing this thing
so we can all have
a potentially beautiful summer.
The Senate is on the verge
of passing a massive COVID
relief plan to help get everyone
through the next few months.
And President Biden
has announced a production deal
that could ensure vaccines
for every American
by the end of May.
Think about that.
Come July 4th,
you could be knocking back
a cold one
in your neighbor's yard
while he flips burgers
and drones on
about how much better
it is to cook with charcoal.
You'll be seeing
so much of your neighbors,
you'll start praying
for the next pandemic.
We could get there.
It's possible.
We just have to spend the next
few months not screwing up,
which of course,
means some governors immediately
started racing
to screw it up.
-The governors of Texas
and Mississippi say
they are lifting nearly all of
their states' coronavirus
restrictions and mask mandates
in the coming days,
now despite new warnings
that the US could soon face
a deadly fourth surge
of the virus.
-Health officials
are warning Americans
should not become complacent
because this pandemic
is not over yet.
We are still seeing roughly
1,500 deaths
every single day
from the virus.
-All businesses of any type
are allowed
to open 100%.
Also, I am ending
the statewide mask mandate.
-Your reaction to the governor's
announcement today?
-Insanity. I'd like to say that
Governor Abbott
has lost his mind.
-In fairness,
maybe he didn't lose it.
Maybe it just froze during
the massive power failure
that happened on his watch.
-Damn it, guys, we're so close.
Why are you doing this now?
You really want people
to congregate at full capacity
in bars and gyms and nightclubs?
I wouldn't even go to a
full capacity nightclub
without a pandemic.
I mean, why?
So I can awkwardly wave my hands
in the air to some EDM
while a jacked due on molly
touches my face
and asks me how Stefon is?
He's fine.
He's fine and he's fictional.
And by the way,
this isn't the fault of Texans.
They need and deserve help and
vaccines as much as anyone else.
It's the fault
of their political leaders.
And look, I get it.
Businesses really
are struggling.
It's still too early
to reopen the riskiest ones,
and we should just be giving
everyone money to survive.
But I understand --
it's a difficult trade off.
But rescinding
the mask mandates?
That's just full insanity.
Masks work.
There's so much proof.
Thanks to masks and
social distancing,
the flu basically
vanished this year.
Meanwhile, South Dakota resisted
a mask mandate
and that state's mortality rate
has been the highest
in the country since last July.
Masks can actually help us
open up more safely.
Plus, I got to be honest,
I'm surprised politicians
that are so pro cowboy hat
find masks uncomfortable.
Maybe it's my weak neck, but I'd
rather wear 100 masks
than one of those big ol' hats.
That's a shame though, because
I look very good and natural
when I wear one.
[ Laughter ]
That's real.
That's not Photoshop.
One of the most galling parts
of rescinding the mask mandates
is that many of the people
who will suffer
most are workers.
The mask isn't just
for your safety,
it's for the safety
of those around you.
Workers who have no choice
but to show up to their jobs
in person will be at risk
and the politicians
will be fine.
So, please, keep wearing a mask.
The last thing
a Footlocker employee needs
is for you to show up maskless
and spend an hour trying on
different sizes of red Yeezys
that are gonna look ridiculous
on you no matter what.
And by the way,
this is the same party
that, as we speak,
is trying to rebrand itself
as a workers' party,
even as they needlessly
put workers in harms way.
In the aftermath
of the Trump presidency,
you've probably heard
a few Republicans
ludicrously trying
to rebrand themselves
as the champions
of the working class.
You know, the same guys who cram
through a $2 trillion tax cut
for corporations and the wealthy
in the dead of night
without a single hearing
and literally scribbled notes
in the margins
at the last minute
to make it easier
for the wealthy
to avoid taxes by using
pass-through companies.
All that stuff Springsteen's
always singing about.
♪ Got a wife and kids
in Baltimore, Jack ♪
♪ But I can claim them
as consultants ♪
♪ And I get it all back ♪
[ Laughter ]
I mean, now it's good.
I had a bad one last week,
but now it's fully
like he's here.
[ Laughter ]
Remember when Elizabeth Warren,
who is now pushing for a wealth
tax on the richest Americans,
that the fake Republican
populists also opposed,
tried to read the text
of the GOP tax cut
and couldn't even make out
what it said?
-They're sending around
their edits as we speak.
"Adjustments attributable to
conversion from S corporat--"
Oh, it's been cut off --
"to corporation.
Section 481 is amended
by adding at the N."
I assume they mean "end,"
but again, it's all cut off.
"The following new subsection,
adjustments
attributable to conversion
for a corporation..."
Something.
C Corporation.
Per in...
Dangerous? That can't be right.
-Sounds like she's trying
to read the text
on a bottle
of Dr. Bronner's.
Made with mint, lavender,
juniper, and...
whale meat?
That can't be right.
By the time they were
done with it,
that bill looked like
a science textbook
you got for six dollars
at an off-campus bookstore,
the one where the last paragraph
says, "As of this publishing,
Jonas Salk is getting
some promising results."
And I have to say,
watching a Harvard professor
try to make heads or tails
of nonsensical writing
gave me chilling flashbacks
to college.
"So that's why Pacino
and De Niro make convincing,
if unlikely, adversaries
in the movie 'Heat.'
Now, Mr. Meyers, you do know
this is a chemistry class,
right?"
"Hey, you're not going
to find better chemistry
than De Niro and Pacino
in their prime.
That is a much
more explosive combo
than hydrogen peroxide
and sodium iodide."
[ Chuckles ]
They should do a remake
of that movie now.
And instead of a diner,
they'd meet virtually.
"Thanks for meeting me
in the Zoom room!
All ready to Zoom tonight,
baby!"
"I can't hear you. Somebody
muted you. Somebody muted you."
"What? I'm on mute?
Nobody mutes
Alfredo James Pacino!
My mic is always hot, baby!
[ Laughter ]
And I'm feeling sky-high!"
It's very nice when there are
no people here...
'cause then I can give
the people what they want.
[ Laughter ]
So, the same guys who wrote
and voted
for that massive giveaway
to corporations and the wealthy
who are needlessly
putting workers in harms way
by repealing mask mandates
and using them as cannon
fodder against the virus
are now trying
to rebrand themselves
as working class populists.
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
tried that last week
at the Conservative
Political Action Conference
and then again this week
on Fox News.
-The Democratic Party
has abandoned
the working class men and women,
the millions of people
who are out of jobs,
who are seeing their wages
pulled down,
who are competing to provide
for their families
with people coming illegally.
That's not who the Democratic
Party represents anymore.
They don't represent
unions anymore.
construction workers
or truck drivers
or working men
and women anymore.
The Republican Party
is not the party
just of the country clubs.
The Republican Party
is the party of steelworkers
and construction workers
and pipeline workers
and taxi cab drivers
and cops and firefighters
and waiters and waitresses
and the men and women
with calluses on their hands
who are working
for this country.
That is our party!
Oh, please, Ted Cruz,
your hands are so delicate
you need an epidural
to get through a manicure.
The only calluses Ted Cruz
has on his hands
or for checking Kayak
on his phone.
Also, I'm willing to bet
the only truck driver Cruz
has ever met is this guy.
But yeah, sure, we all believe
you're a pro-union,
blue-collar guy who's fighting
for working people
from your flight
to the Ritz-Carlton in Cancun.
I'm sure
those construction workers
you're pretending to care
about are thrilled
that, thanks to the tax bill
you voted for,
they can finally convert their
S corporations to C corporations
and use their corporate
pass-through vehicles
to reduce their tax liability.
Everybody remembers
the famous photo of steelworkers
sitting atop a skyscraper.
But did you know they wrote off
those lunchboxes
as business expenses
by funneling their income
through a limited
liability company?
But if Ted Cruz and his fellow
faux-populist hucksters
like Missouri Senator
Josh Hawley,
really wanted to prove
they're supposed pro-union
blue-collar bona fides,
they could easily speak up
in favor of a courageous
and unprecedented union drive
by Amazon workers in Alabama,
because right now those workers
are bravely taking on
one of the richest and most
powerful companies in the world.
And the company is going to
extreme lengths to stop them.
-An historic labor showdown
in Alabama tonight
involving the world's largest
online retailer,
and it's drawing the attention
of the White House.
Thousands of workers
at an Amazon warehouse
voting on whether to form
the company's first labor union
in the U.S.
Amazon pushing employees
to vote no.
-Bessemer, Alabama, is home
to an Amazon warehouse
where about 6,000 employees
are voting right now
on whether to form the Internet
giant's first union in the U.S.
It's a bitter battle.
Warehouse employees like
Jennifer Bates
constantly get texts
from Amazon,
warning that union
dues could leave them
with less money
than they already have.
Anti-union fliers
are even posted
inside a warehouse
bathroom stalls.
-First of all, Amazon, stop
sending anti-union texts.
In fact, stop sending
texts in general.
Amazon texts me
more than my wife,
especially when I ask her
about one of my impressions.
Seriously, Amazon,
I don't need a text every time
I place an order,
then another one
when that order's received,
and then another
when the package is shipped,
and another
when it's dropped off.
What's next --
a text when my neighbor gets mad
that I left the package
in the hallway for too long
and reports me
to the co-op board
for a disciplinary hearing?
Janet, I know you've been trying
to get me kicked out
because you hate my welcome mat,
but too bad
because I think it's funny...
and we need to laugh, Janet!
It's hard to overstate
just how seismic
and historic
this union drive is.
Amazon workers are fighting
against the largest retailer
in the world
run by one of the richest men
in the world,
which is going all out
to stop them.
-Why do you want to join a
union?
-Because I feel like we need
an amplified voice.
We've been talking to Amazon
about issues that we've had
and they've ignored us,
so we need a sense of security
and a louder voice
and better wages.
-Amazon hired a group
of union buster consultants
that they paid each consultant
$3,200 a day
to try to convince these people
to vote against theirselves.
Amazon is no more than when
we look at things down there,
it's a sweat shop
and people are out there
just working --
They have to touch a package.
Every eight seconds
they have to touch a package.
They're only allowed
two 30-minute break a day.
-They have to touch a package
every eight seconds?
That's insane.
Not even
the TSA works that fast.
[ Laughter ]
Fred, where's my rimshot?
Fred, that joke clearly called
for a rimshot, buddy.
Okay, you know what? We're going
to have to have a meeting.
Well, where was I?
Oh, right.
They have to touch a package
every eight seconds.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
Just too late, Fred.
But also, it's insane they
only get two 30-minute breaks.
They're essential workers
employed by a company
whose CEO increased his wealth
by $75 billion in 2020
and they basically kept
the entire country
running during a pandemic.
Without Amazon, I probably
would have had to camp out
at Trader Joe's for toilet paper
like the standby line
for SNL when BTS performs
or when I hosted.
You should have seen the line.
[ Wind howls ]
I did not sign off
on adding a tumbleweed.
[ Laughter ]
This is an actual fight
by courageous
working-class union organizers
against a corporate Goliath.
If you were to actually take
the pretend populists
of the GOP at their word,
this is the exact kind of thing
they supposedly care about,
and yet they've been silent.
Meanwhile, Biden released
a major
and truly unprecedented video
in support of the effort
and without
mentioning Amazon by name,
warned companies
to stop intimidating workers
who want to unionize.
-The choice to join a union
is up to the workers --
full stop.
Full stop.
Today and over the next few days
and weeks, workers in Alabama
and all across America
are voting
on whether to organize
a union in their workplace.
This is vitally important --
a vitally important choice.
And there should be
no intimidation, no coercion,
no threats,
no anti-union propaganda.
No supervisor, no supervisors
should confront employees
about their union preferences.
-And of course
Joe came out for the union.
He was one of those guys
eating lunch on that skyscraper.
You think he's going
to be out-blue-collared
by Ted Cruz, of all people?
He's ridden Amtrak
so many times,
he's probably got
a railroad union card.
If politics didn't work out,
his fallback plan was working
in the snack car on the Acela.
"We got gum and coffee,
and that's it."
So Biden came out forcefully
in favor of union rights.
And yet we've heard
radio silence
from the so-called populists
of the Republican Party
who pretend to be pro-worker
and anti-big tech,
although in fairness,
they do have much more important
things going on right now.
-Well, first it was
Mr. Potato Head
and Mrs. Potato Head,
now it's Dr. Seuss.
-They want to cancel
the Muppets.
They want to cancel
Mr. and Mrs. Potato Head.
So when will this stop?
-You see last week they tried
to cancel Kermit the Frog
and Mr. Potato Head?
You see that?
-Look out, Mr. Potato Head.
You're next.
-If I wanted to buy one
and let's say
I had the boy at home
and I wanted the girl,
the box is going to say
"potato head."
How am I going to know
which one I'm getting?
-This week alone, they canceled
Mr. Potato Head.
You know, this week alone,
they canceled the Muppets.
You know, they're canceling
Dr. Seuss.
-First, they outlawed Dr. Seuss
and now they want
to tell us what to say.
-Ah, yes, the party
of the working class,
if class in this case
means third grade.
Do you guys really think
any actual adult
in their right mind cares
about a few Dr. Seuss books
getting pulled from publication
because of racist imagery?
Even my kids don't care
about Dr. Seuss.
They want to watch the League
of Legends World Championship,
even though I'm still trying
to get them into
my favorite board game,
"Ocean Master,"
which has a new expansion
pack called "Port of Call."
The way it works is
you get skill cards
for every port you dock at,
which helps you mine resources
which translate to gold coins,
which you can then use
to hire deckhands
who help you find islands
where you collect minerals,
and whoever collects
the most minerals
gets to pick
a different game to play.
Republicans are preposterously
trying to rebrand themselves
as a party of
working-class populists,
despite the fact
that they're still in lockstep
behind a racist
billionaire tax cheat
who helped them dole out
trillions in tax cuts
to corporations
and the wealthy.
And now they're needlessly
putting workers in harms way
by prematurely
lifting mask mandates.
And one of them flew
to a luxury resort in Cancun
while his constituents
froze to death.
Meanwhile, courageous
Amazon workers in Alabama
need and deserve the support,
and Republicans are silent.
Turns out
there's only one worker
they're willing to stand up for,
and that's...
-Mr. Potato Head.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe,
wash your hands, wear a mask.
We love you.